des sourires des applaudissements et des
familles surprise de retrouver des arts
vivants bien envie aux quarts de leurs
parcs de quartier et les gars beaucoup
l'intérêt mais une pièce de théâtre
expérience
le rêve de monsieur paul lotterie sort
de la roulotte est un conte théâtral qui
raconte de manière fantaisiste la folle
aventure de cette vénérable institution
fondée en 1952
ça fait soixante huit ans que ça existe
dans ce projet là c'est du génie non sur
ce que c'est tellement le fun que ça
existe puis qu'on puisse offrir ça à des
jeunes tous les étés puis que ça se
perpétue d'année en année comme ceci ça
veut dire que l'idée même à la base
était brillante et importante qui j'ai
peu de la maison seule la cause d'un
rouleau de la roulotte et pis mon école
a été l'école à tout le monde
paul buissonneau un immigrant français
débarque au québec et fraudes en 1952
avec claude robillard alors directeur
des parcs de montréal
la roulotte un véhicule de diffusion
culturelle dans les parcs qui deviendra
une institution claude robillard eu
cette idée
il y avait ce vieux véhicules
restauration y est allé voir paul
buissonneau le noyau de ce qui fait la
roulotte pour moi c'est le véhicule et
tout ce qui évoque tout ce qui porte de
magie d'histoires vraies ou inventées et
de compte aussi l'idée un peu comme dans
des sports amateurs c'est de réunir des
gens des quartiers autour d'une ferveur
commune mais cette fois les théâtres moi
je pense fondamentalement que c'est
essentiel que c'est un droit d'avoir
accès au théâtre et de ses enfants
c'est leur première pièce qu'ils vont
voir
une troupe qui depuis 68 ans initié le
public et forment la relève de jean
louis millette aller dans la brèche d'or
ce sont des générations de comédiens qui
ont fait leurs premières armes a déclaré
note cette année c'est au tour des
diplômés de 2020 et 2021 de l'école
nationale de théâtre et du conservatoire
je me souviens je suis rentrée au
conservatoire puis j'avais vu les années
précédentes de la roulotte petit ont
amené voir la roulotte fait que c'était
déjà quelque chose qui se dessinait dans
ma tête de dire waouh j'aimerais en
faire partie pour éviter créer des
attroupements les dates et les lieux des
représentations ne seront pas annoncés à
l'avancé il faut donc ouvrir l'oeil ou
encore l'oreille parce que la troupe
également créé un balado des comptes
avec la participation de marcel sabourin
pour poursuivre cette belle tradition
d'aller à la rencontre du public où
qu'ils soient et peu importe les
circonstances et s'il est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal